Bookstores are portals to amazing adventures
and stories brought right to your fingertips, literally.
I'm self-educated, I taught myself from books
by going to bookstores.
So I'm so passionate about reading
because it can change your life.
It teaches about history, geography, humanity, poetry, love,
just everything, everything can be found through reading.
But not everyone has access.
I was lucky when I was younger to be able to go
and purchase books or go to the libraries.
And in Manhattan, there are 70 bookstores
to find your next great read,
but head to the Bronx and there's only one.
Our next guest is a Drew Gooder determined to change that
one book at a time.
Please watch this.
My name is Latanya DeVaughn and I am from the Bronx.
I am the proud owner of Bronx Bound Books,
a bookstore on wheels.
Right now the Bronx only has one brick and mortar bookstore.
I believe a bookstore should be a staple in every community.
Sometimes the kids in the Bronx don't have access to books
until they're in a school building.
My mission is to make book ownership accessible
and affordable.
I purchased an old bus and took out all the seats
and flooring and converted it
into a beautiful bookstore on wheels.
We sell books at weekly farmer's markets.
We visit schools, we go to shelters
and we also host various book drives.
There's such a huge misconception
about the people in the Bronx not wanting to read.
I see young people all the time get excited about reading.
Some kids come on and they can't believe
there's so many books,
others come on and just sit down and just wanna read.
They think it's a genius idea
for a bus to be turned into a bookstore.
Bronx Bound Books feels like more than a dream come true.
It's more than I could have ever imagined it to be.
I wake up every day thinking of new ways to improve
how to serve my community
and to make my dream even bigger.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
Please welcome, Latanya DeVaughn.
Hello.
Where did you get this idea?
I always wanted to own a bookstore.
All my friends knew, and I was just having a conversation.
I was getting ready to quit one of my jobs,
and my friend Vanessa said,
"You know, Latanya, you have to just do the bookstore.
You keep talking about this."
And I'm like, well, the rent is so high in the Bronx.
Gentrification is happening
and things are just really, really changing.
And I said, "I'm never gonna be able to afford
a brick and mortar."
So one day she just showed me a picture of a book truck
and that was all it took for me to find the inspiration
to do a bookstore on wheels.
This is so genius.
Thank you, thank you.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
Now, this is personal for you.
Will you tell us why this is personal for you?
Well, I grew up with my grandmother and she was a teacher.
Not only did she teach the children in the Bronx,
sometimes on any given Saturday,
I could come to my living room
and I would see her reading to her neighbors
who couldn't read.
So she would read leases, cable bills,
and just explain to them why
or when they needed to take their medicine.
So seeing that showed me that reading was just something
that could really change and save your life.
I see the kids there.
That's what, you know-
(audience applauds)
It does start there.
Well, we told the publisher A Kids Company About
all about you, and they're gonna give you $5,000 worth
of empowering educational kids books.
Wow.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
And then I'm gonna match it and give you $5,000
just to enable whatever you see fit
and how to spend that money.
Thank you so much.
I'm so in awe of what you do
and it is an honor to bring your story to light,
to support you in our tiny, small way,
and just say, keep going, 'cause you are such a hero.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
You are so amazing.
Thank you, Latanya.
You can learn more about Bronx Bound Books
on thedrewbarrymoreshow.com,
where you'll be featured on our website.
(upbeat bright music)